hey what's up guys max holbert here with
kevin van norden uh and we're jumping
into some watch dogs
hey how's it going going well we're
going to watch some doc you're going to
watch
some dogs playing some watch dogs see
what i did there yeah it's a joke it's a
joke see see i'm doing i'm doing good at
jokes so i don't i didn't come in like i
was i was tapped for this uh a little
bit earlier so i didn't come i'm not
coming with any specific things in mind
this is uh i'm playing actually under uh
rob hanlery's gamer tag so uh we we
gotta see what what rob's been up to
and uh for now we should probably choose
something to do so hopefully we'll do a
bunch of stuff we'll maybe do some story
stuff do some open world stuff do some
multiplayer stuff and so on and so forth
but he's still early in the game so uh
this is a location that triggers a
memory so let's let's drive that way
what what is the basic
flow of gameplay
so
in terms of flow
watchdogs is very much like a lot of
city-based open-world games in the sense
that you have story missions to go to
that that sort of flesh out the story
and keep things moving forward from a
narrative perspective but in between you
have a lot of side things to do
um and then the multiplayer is built
into the single player experience so
when you when you join a multi-player
match sometimes there's a loading screen
and stuff like that but a lot of things
just take place in the world where
you're existing
um
you know but hopefully i can show some
of that maybe i'll be lucky and i'll get
hacked while we play and you can see how
the hacking works
um when another player basically jumps
in and invades your world and then tries
to steal information from you and your
goal is to find that person and kill
them
so he just wants the information and
then wants to get away
you want to kill him
um
which is fairly violent i guess when you
think about it
you know killing killing it all
but if you have any questions
let me know absolutely i'm reading the
chat so
anything you want to ask
i'm in here yeah and you can you can
watch uh
you're there watching on twitch which is
twitch
dot tv slash game spot or on game spot
itself
um but it's easiest for us to get
questions in the twitch chat so yeah so
uh feel free to to pop into both places
if
if you want to get some immediate
communication going on but in the game
you do play as aiden pierce i am out for
revenge um i used to be a basically a
hacker for hire and
at one point i during a
a heist in a hotel
where me and my buddy were stealing some
stuff um like hacking into rich people's
accounts and stealing their money
um got on somebody's wrong side
and
people don't like their money stolen and
then they hired and then
somebody was hired to come after me
while i was driving they shot out my
tire my niece was with me and she died
in the accident and now
aidan's uh out for revenge and here's
actually a little bit of this is
actually a little bit of a story bit
this is a recollection
is this it
well you get to see the uh this is
basically aidan's memory
of the accident so it's uh it's kind of
it does a thing where it's like filtered
through memories and a little a little
bit of that hacky art style
so it's a really interesting way to
present this it sort of reminds me of
how
our memories actually do work piecing
together
bits of information rather than being a
complete it's not like
our minds video graph the whole thing
and then play it back it so this sort of
reminds me of what uh that's kind of
cool what a memory actually
sort of feels like in a way
although i don't know that there's a
good visual representation of
of a series of memories for example but
this is as good as any i've seen i think
it's interesting i i i
i don't know if i've ever seen a a
gravestone that indicates somebody's age
like that it says her death date but it
also says what her age was
which is which is sort of interesting
it's for people that don't do math well
yeah but that's that's sort of sad
so uh maybe i'll go and do something a
little more
a little more uplifting i'm looking to
see if there's a ctos
tower for me to hack but
i i think i'm going to have to go ahead
and continue the story so i can unlock
the rest of that stuff luckily that
doesn't take long
you do have a skill tree and a bunch of
other things like that but
before you unlock all of it you have to
actually get to a certain place in the
story before all of those things become
open to you
so we'll go and see what the next story
mission has
has in store all right
uh
somebody with a terrible green name here
in the twitch chat
angel usually maybe
uh how's the driving compared to
sleeping dogs or grand theft auto i
didn't play much of sleeping dogs
so i can't really say
and
the driving
is arcady
so
you know certainly if you're expecting a
a driving experience that feels more
like forza or gt you're going to be
disappointed it's actually
cars that are that look heavy feel
rather heavy and and
but on the other hand um a lot of the
cars are very slippy and slidy okay and
very bouncy so the physics are pretty
bouncy
um yeah the physics are pretty loose but
i came to really enjoy the driving as a
matter of fact in part because because
of that bounciness so for example
there's
one of my favorite ways to escape the
cops is to uh open a bridge as i
approach it and go flying up you know up
the span and across and leaving the cops
behind me and it's all the more exciting
because you you get a lot of well you
see example right there you get a lot of
air
um and there's a lot of
you know there's a lot of bouncing
involved so the physics are
are loose and and rather uh
so speaking of running away from cops
there's no cops in the water there are
no cops in the water um but if i maybe
i'll uh try to get the cops on my case
here
after this i'll try to do the story
mission first and then we'll we'll get
the cops on get the cops on me i'll i'll
try to steal a few cars and see if i can
get the the cops attention and then
maybe we'll escape off to the water
which is my second favorite kind of
escape after the bridges it's going
oh nice i got out i i hit the y button
by accident that was my own stupid fault
because i i went to hit x
that's all right there's a mini
get out of there soccer mom i'm heading
this way x to hack button yeah x is a
hack button and i and i uh i hit both x
and y at the same time so i hacked into
the billboard at the same time that i
left out of the out of the vehicle
fun times fun times how frequently do
you find yourself hacking things
all the time you're always hacking
things um part of that though
is
it's not as hacky as you think a lot of
that simply means
activating things in the environment
in in some way so sometimes even though
it's called hacking sometimes all you're
doing is like
raising a forklift yeah for instance um
or you're you're opening a gate or
you're causing a steam pipe to explode
beanies i'm gonna double my weapons
so this is where
oh i remember this is where you have to
to buy an assault rifle
is this like a standard weapon store
yeah this is a standard weapon store
it's funny though like eventually you
find so much stuff
that
i never really bought much
over the course of the game because most
of it just flowed freely okay like you
pick up charlotte gardner you know your
enemies weapons
for instance so i rarely bought weapons
although i did buy every single you know
a grenade launcher and a sniper rifle in
particular
so let's get over here
continue on the early campaign
and um i haven't been invited to an
online thing yet but we can get into an
online thing in a bit
usually like a lot of the time and this
usually comes later
um i think the game serving their
country specifically keeps you from
being invited into too much online stuff
in the early hours before you
open up
everything and then suddenly the uh the
offers
to get into online races and and other
things kind of come fast and furious
especially if you've started hacking
people or they've started hacking you
because you often get the chance to like
provide retribution to to people that
hacked into you
by getting a chance to like uh teach
them a lesson oh sorry
i need access
i had to find out who's targeting my
family so yeah i have barely unlocked
much here so phone call
let's see how this goes
so what is ctos is that ctos is
basically the uh
there we go see
ctos is the system is chicago's computer
system that basically
stores
everybody's information okay and uh it's
also the surveillance system
so i think what i'll do is i'll
that can't be normal
here
so now you start to see some of the
things i can do in the environment
although i'm not doing anything very
interesting right now
so let's uh let's hack into you know we
can hack into some cameras here and sort
of get a feel i'll
so i need to get the access code so it
looks like he's a dude with an access
code so i can just hack him right from
the camera without actually having to
move
this guy eventually we might be able to
distract let's go to this camera and see
what's going on
camera hopping can be really really
useful for a lot of reasons
i'm not going to get much out of this
angle here yeah
jesus
but the world doesn't stop just because
i'm in cameras and that's
now i've i've started picking up some
some other weapons
can you drag bodies to hide them you
cannot that is not part
of
this game's particular brand of stealth
okay
i wish i had a silenced pistol here
i'm looking to see if there's a
all right so here
i'll burst that and it might draw him
over there
so i can sneak past
like so
so sometimes you just want to distract
dudes
is there is there a way to kind of move
through
a lot of things without being noticed at
all and not getting a gun fight yeah you
can totally uh skip past a bunch of gun
fights
if you want the
the bad news if you can call it bad news
is that the shooting is really really
easy
so now i'm hacking in and now i get to
do the hacking mini game which in this
particular case is super easy
but these actually do get
more
more challenging as you go
and remember i'm still in the world
so
so you can be caught right so i can be
caught right now yes
so we'll hack into this this might so
this is gonna pull up the randomizer so
i'm gonna rant like like hack into some
random computer somewhere and you often
get a
a look at what people are doing in the
privacy of their own homes in this case
this guy is being
this guy's being normal he's just
looking at stars through his telescope
but
a lot of the time in fact i would say
most of the time you see people doing
things that they wouldn't necessarily
want to be caught
doing
um so
i could imagine
what's inside someone's home
let's look into this one is
you often see
you know sex acts in progress
cannibals having a meal
this guy's telling his sleeping wife or
girlfriend
that she's a nasty piece of [ __ ] he's
gonna murder her and put her head
in the cabinet
fine
you can go back to sleep okay
yeah i love you too
oh see that's that's
i have very mixed feelings about that
aspect of the game because it it's it's
a little bit try too hard if you know
what i mean like it's trying so hard to
make everybody seem like an [ __ ]
right um
so at this point you've got a contact
that helps you out through your through
your missions called batboy17 but
it doesn't actually take long for bad
boy 17 to be revealed you actually learn
who this person is
um very very soon in the game so all
kinds of stuff
when you start playing if you see this
don't think that bad boy 17's identity
ends up becoming a traffic
a major
you know
if i can see them mystery or anything
because that's that's opened up pretty
quickly so this is basically a uh
another player hack
thing okay
so now i'm but remember i'm still here
and then what happens now it's time to
get out all that stuff is happening do
you get sucked out of the hack
oh yeah you get sucked out of the hack
okay and then you
have to deal with the trouble that
you've caused and then once you kind of
finish your gunfight or whatever you can
just go back into it
yeah you can go back into it okay
typically
yeah this is uh
this was fun because i didn't actually
get into any action
so i mean that's how i in watch dogs
that's often how i prefer it although
i'm not against uh doing the shootie
shootie when i need to sure um and
there's actually uh a nice little move
you can pull off
oops i better holster my gun before
people start bitching
people on the uh
surrounding me will be like
the dude's got a gun wait is that the
guy they call the vigilante
how they always can figure that out it's
not quite clear this is one of those
cases where i think they would have been
better off
not having
passersby acknowledge me because i don't
want to be acknowledged and i'm it's not
always clear how it is that they figured
out who i am so here's the early skill
tree this is not the full skill tree
um this actually opens up even more
so here's uh
so i think i'm going to unlock
some hacking skills one is opening
bridges because it's my favorite type of
escape
um this one unlocks blockers which i can
pull pull up um during traffic or i can
in
i can add a battery slot you need for
major hacks you need a a battery slot
and then that gradually refills just to
recharge your phone no no that just
happens kind of automatically so i'm
going to choose blockers and then you
have
you have notoriety skills which is based
on your
your
notoriety and that's that essentially
comes from
earning
you know earning a reputation
online okay
we hack somebody yeah let's totally hack
somebody
so uh
let's see here
so we can do online tailing
a mobile challenge online decryption
online hacking let's do some uh
oh i have to complete the introduction
to unlock
so and that's what's happening right
here i think yeah hey i need you to
cover something so this is my associate
jordy who is the game's funniest
character no
he's uh kind of a fast talking associate
so i need to move him who tends to get
me in a little bit of
trouble
all right but right now i'm gonna i'm
gonna hack into uh
into a ctos
tower here which involves a little bit
of uh puzzle solving and sometimes a
little bit of
a little bit of uh navigation to figure
out
don't let me put you out i said i'd
handle it
so if anybody in the chat is from
chicago i'd like to know if if if uh
everybody there is a freak like watchdog
says you are or
uh
my brother lives in chicago is he a
freak i wonder oh man that would be
great if he were
all right so we've arrived here
and we will come around
and so the trick is going to be
basically there's going to be
the tower up there to hack into
so part of the trick
is to figure out how to actually get up
there
um so this is where some of the fun
begins you usually when you do these you
end up wandering around a little bit
so
hacking into that person we get to see
the uh the text message and this is a
text message that actually uh
unlocks a package location and those
package locations usually just have some
um crafting materials for you or some
ammo stuff like that so but you end up
uh having to go through the entire uh
text message
again everybody in chicago is pretty
much an ass
so everybody's doing something they
shouldn't be doing
so by hacking into him i have a new
vehicle
that has come available that's also how
you earn some
some new tunes as well that guy's nice
he volunteers at a homeless shelter yeah
there are well there are some nice
people that's what keeps uh
watchdogs version of chicago from being
a complete [ __ ]
pardon my french
are there any air vehicles there
are not you have to fend off
police helicopters okay but you can't
fly any yeah but see for now
i'm guessing that i'm gonna need to come
over here all right so here we go
here's a lift i'm gonna go up in the
lift and
there's a camera let me get into that
camera now
so now we're now we're cooking with
crisco now so you see you can see the
you know the lines here that show you
sort of the the power connections but it
looks like we're gonna need to do more
because
this one still is not uh
powered up
but i doubt we'll need to do anything
from oh there's a camera up there
there we go there's the other
unlock
so now we've probably
unlocked all the doors
that we need to unlock and now the trick
is just going to be
how to actually
get in
so you can do a bit of climbing you do a
bit of climbing it's not the game's not
assassin's creed it's not like you're
doing a whole lot of that
but when it comes to unlocking these
towers you do end up having to navigate
around a bit okay
and then it looks like we'll need to
come around a little more climbing
and here we go here is the
now by hacking into the tower i unlock
additional objectives through through
the region so in that sense it's very
much like the second street and far cry
so
you know you've you've hacked into this
particular
area okay and now it
you know the influence spreads and now i
have these additional things that i can
do
and so it you know says hey here's the
map why don't you try this so then uh
you know opens pawn shops
um here is uh
that drop-off location that the text was
talking about
these are all the hot spots are
basically like four square
i'll show you what those are like since
there's one real close the hot spots are
like four squares so you just go in and
check in but there's a little bit more
to it than that in the sense that you
can
leave uh
leave gifts for people that also check
in
and these are like other players you
mean yeah other players you can totally
um leave money
for other people or ammo or whomever so
let's hop back into
glad it's still here with its broken
window and everything
i guess i could have just
walked there's no reason not to just
walk across the street to the theater
so as you can see as you hover over
people you see all this information
um
you know like she's a server and an
artist
um so the question is if i hack into her
i might end up stealing money so is that
something that i actually want to do in
this case
you end up just uh
reading her text
the unicorn ate my rainbow
what is going on
okay that was weird
so he's talking with a potential
criminal
and this this will unlock a crime
location and you can
you can uh interrupt crimes in progress
so
after i check in maybe we'll do uh the
crime
so yeah i'll place the waypoint of the
crime first i'll come over here and
we'll check in at this spot
so that's uh that's the tutorial
for checking in
so it tells you a little information
not every spot
in watch dogs
represents a real place in chicago but
most do
okay
so this will show you some history from
um the theater of the world
but also
you can leave gifts here you can see
that dino man zero zero has been here
and checked in three times
and uh you can also leave gifts or you
know obviously collect gifts so you do
get a certain
gift allotment per day it just comes
from showing from donation
is there a benefit to leaving cash for
somebody or
i don't i don't know because why why
would i as a player leave my money
just because you're a nice person
that's why i'm gonna do it i'm gonna go
ahead and leave a gift even though i
just took some money so um
i don't know i might as well go ahead
and leave some meds too
i'll leave some meds
there we go
somebody out there will uh benefit
from the medication that i just left
them
so uh oh
just hack into some random people i just
stole
740 dollars from uh
oh
we had batteries no
hopefully that's uh
hopefully everything will be fine
but uh if anybody is watching we may
need new batteries in the controller
either that or we might just be too far
from the xbox sometimes that happens too
uh-oh i think i might have made a cop
mad
but over here
there's a crime in progress okay
all right
uh while we're going there we're going
to do a little quick ad break uh and
maybe put some batteries in our
controller
the wonder of batteries we got new
batteries for the controller so i'm
happy so where was i oh yes i was
tailing a criminal
so it shows you his crime probability
you got to make sure he doesn't catch
you though
because otherwise
you won't be able to catch him in the
act
so i'm going to zoom over like this
graduate student multiple public
intoxication charges
sounds familiar
that'll teach you oh
that's right that's right this guy
designs cosplay costumes for a living i
love that
or maybe not for a living only because
you saved him
yeah the cosplay community frequently
purchases cookbooks
gang hideout oh gang hideouts are fun
maybe i'll actually do some shooting
this time okay all right and a skill
point acquired let's uh
this time let's do something with
shooting so that i can
there we go all right so now i'm gonna
try to get into some shooting here
i'll uh try to
true hope faith in the chat actually
makes a good point that i noticed is
that the mini map is on the right
and in a lot of games it's on the left
it's on the left that's true and that
was something that that confused me for
a bit when i first looked at the game
you know what i never actually thought
twice about it yeah to tell you the
truth it never really uh but part of
that's um
i like gta but
i haven't played gta 5 in a long time so
that's not really
did i pass by the the thing
oh it's right there it is it is right
there
so it never really bothered me um
because it's it's so much right there
and i i don't really
and i guess when i'm paying attention to
it is when i'm actually in a in a
shootout where it does seem to to be
sort of a natural place for it to be for
me maybe because i'm i'm right-handed
okay
so anyway let's activate this mission
my first instinct is to put a bullet i
like the gang hideouts actually um
i can do what they're because they're
essentially just stand-alone combat
encounters okay um i'll pull him off his
pedestal humiliate him in front of his
crew
i'll show them that although you
typically you uh you don't want to kill
necessarily usually you have to take
down one without killing him all right
like the the leader or something right
so in this case i'm gonna actually have
to profile
the target now listening to on her
conversation
really easily we have nothing to talk
about now ever
jeez
that's rude
i don't like hockey either so there
all right so
camera up here let's take a look around
scope out the joint
he's a it says his occupation is scam
artist
he's on the neighborhood watch man
so there's a there's a lot of stuff
going on here that i can play with
remotely
one fun thing to do
i'm not going to distract him yet
he can call reinforcements
eventually you can unlock this is the
guy i have to knock down okay
so this guy can call reinforcements and
eventually you can actually
you actually get a perk uh a thing where
that'll let you disable reinforcements
so i think see this guy is like staring
me straight in the face and i don't know
so here we go i have
lures
so i'm going to activate
oh man activate his face yeah
death by face
so
i think what i might do for the fun of
it
is to uh
is to
throw a lure over there
attract somebody over
and then i'm going to explode
that thing on the wall
there you go
problem is of course that that draws
attention
i don't care what it takes find him
and i have to remember not to shoot the
main dude
okay you just gotta knock him down yeah
oh i didn't see that dude
oh
all worked out oh wrong button
all right
the guy have to knock down
he's calling oh he's calling
reinforcements
great
that's all right i'm prepared
is there anything i can do to soften
these dudes up a little bit
those guys are coming from over there
ouch all right
someone check him he's dead
there's also a little bit of a
a slow down mechanic too
i'll show you that in a minute like a
bullet time thing oh yeah
oh like that
good for a head shot here again
that's right i killed him in the hand
you got that right
who needs head shots when you can okay
that guy is carrying a grenade
there's a guy over here carrying a
grenade that i can actually hack
remotely and you can come over here and
i can blow up his grenades so
there we go let's watch that happen
hopefully somebody will get close to him
holy [ __ ]
so he tried to get rid of it and he just
kind of threw it at his own feet and
that didn't move out of the way so i
can't say that the ai is particularly
brilliant
one of the downsides of the game is that
the shooting is
is fairly easy
oh man he had an online dating account
that was really mean oh that guy has a
has an exploding grenade too
so how do you know that because when you
hover over it it'll tell you what
available there is
okay
how do you turn it off what is doing up
there
what are you doing dude
that's not how you that's not how you
you criminal
although to be fair i i fell into his
little trap
uh in the multiplayer can you play cross
platform
no no
there you are [ __ ]
oh there's a little guy next there's a
guy next to him i didn't even notice him
bye he really knows you either oh he was
deaf in one ear now he's definitely
oh there's a sniper up there
all right we're gonna leave
out of my way
she killed the guys
but left the leader alive
and that's it
yeah i had this that's the plan that
that that was the plan i i don't know
that they always make sense but it was
fun so that's that's the part that
matters most to me let's get into
something online even though i can't do
it even though it looks like there's no
hacking
available for me quite yet because i
haven't done the
the tutorial thing for it yet um there
are a couple of really fun things to do
so there's there's online free roam
but you can you can just tool around
with people but decryption is one of my
favorite things to do but let's
let's start with an online race i think
that that uh
is a good place to go it'll search for a
race
and uh in the meanwhile
we can just tool around
so now that i can hack into bridges i
can open it and then one of my favorite
things is to actually
well i didn't do that that one very well
but that's that's particularly fun when
the cops are on your tail let's see if i
can annoy the cops
oh a good way to do that is to steal a
car
i think about shooting people
oh that'll do it too because that's a
different approach oh i can't hack those
people because i haven't i haven't
hacked into the so these guys are
playing an ar mini game every so often
you get to play them too
every so often though you'll get to see
dudes
hanging around
um like just pointing their their
fingers in the air like they've got guns
they're playing they are mini games
so uh
oh no no that's not going to help
stealing a car that way doesn't help i
have to steal i have to actually hijack
a car
out of there
and he'll call 9-1-1
he's calling 9-1-1
he's doing it secretly though what's
your emergency we need cops here
i'm just hanging around all right so now
i'm in if i escape this area before the
house find me um i'll be all right okay
but sometimes they'll have multiple
areas that they check they're checking
at one time all right but now the police
are in pursuit
so now the uh the fun begins or the
annoyance depending on how you feel
about police chases in open world games
i'm going to take a little bit of a
shortcut here
there is a lot of builds
yeah there's a lot of bounce even in a
car this this car feels particularly
heavy yeah so
open this bridge
will they not cross it well if they
won't cross it oh here we go into the
online race anyway there you go
so i don't know if anybody's played
split second maybe out in the chat so
races are have a little bit of that
split second vibe because you're you're
triggering explosions and things in the
environment around you to mess up
everybody else's racing okay
it's nothing quite as dramatic as in
split second or even in motor storm
apocalypse where you like make giant
changes to the environment
but uh
so people are voting on the
the on the race so i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna vote for random race because
everybody else is fighting for random
race so hopefully i won't make too big
of a fool of myself in an online race
so and then this is just gonna whisk me
into the race and it will
the thing is at the end of the race then
you just remain where you are in your
version of the world which is kind of
interesting like it'll whisk you away
but when it's done it doesn't set you
back where you were it just puts you
where you happen to be
when the race ends okay
again if you guys have any questions
about the game uh feel free to chat on
twitch
uh
or if you just want to share your
opinions on bacon yeah or that yeah i'm
here
i don't know how anybody can have an
opinion that bacon is not delicious
however that's
that doesn't make any sense
here we go
these are all people these are all
actual people no bots
there are shortcuts
and there's nitro which i just activated
yeah you can pick up some nitro
whoa oops
somebody did activate uh
activated some environmental crap there
though yeah
we
like i picked up a
i haven't
somebody dropped out you rude mfr
lpk chichu montana
you suck
oh man
truck getting in the way
oh my vehicle my my doors are in bad
shape
oh no
nice lap
that king eight
coming for you dude
so once once an environment is triggered
you can't trigger it again is that right
um that's true in that race i don't
think you can trigger that steam pipe
again for example
oh he's messing up this is the time this
is my time to take the lead can i do it
sometimes just oh
man
it's so close but i love at the end
like you get a little bit you get a
little bit of uh
tooling around that you can do
so we'll be able to get out of vehicles
after uh everybody's finished
see it's kind of whoa
that's always fun
see right now i can't like interact i
have no interaction except for camera
control um but as soon as the
the countdown is done
around
we'll do another one then maybe we'll do
uh
you can't actually kill anybody like you
just you just tool around
at this point
so everybody on their own screen is
aiden pierce right oh hello everybody on
your own screen is aiden yeah on your
own screen you're always aiding pierce
to other people you just look like
random
people and it looks like that race
session's over
since uh
the guy that was hosting it quit
oh criminal convoy here's something we
can do let's do a criminal conversation
you're back in europe so i'm now back in
my own world okay
excuse me i want your truck
i like your i like your jacket lady
oh she's calling 9-1-1 crap let's uh
worry about staying away from the cops
first
in my
big clunky vehicle that i stole
hopefully i can just avoid being caught
oh man
okay sure uh affinati says what's the
difference between the hacking blackout
and the crafting blackout
the hacking blackout in the craft oh
when you you can hack a blackout um
object that basically causes a blackout
or you can hack into a power
um a power box that causes a blackout
i think we just need the um
the xbox to be a little closer
um as it turns out i don't think it was
the batteries that were the cause of the
problem
my reputation went down a little bit
because i injured some people
um but the reputation
is is such a meaningless thing really it
has no effect really i mean it has some
um but it's not something that's so
meaningful that i think people are
usually going to pay attention to it
okay um
i mean in so far as morality systems are
concerned this morality system is not
that gamified so in other words any
morality that exists from you stealing
money from people that are poor for
example or from killing dudes that just
got married or have cancer or something
sure that's that's your morals to
grapple with the game doesn't give you a
whole lot of extrinsic rewards
for that stuff
which i'm fine yeah there's some
questions about the multiplayer hacking
yeah um
so when you go into multiplayer hacking
you
are what what is your role when you are
trying to hack if you hack somebody else
your role is to
is to get to the player
um initiate the hack
and then stay out of their line of sight
and so that they don't identify you so
your goal is to not be seen you can
either blend in
you can just walk around or you can get
in a vehicle and drive a little bit but
you have to stay within a certain circle
okay and as time goes over the circle
gets smaller and smaller
so actually
let's uh
get uh let's let's get the uh the story
underway so we can actually do some
online hacking i think that sounds like
the most appropriate thing to do
so that people can actually see a hack
in progress oh by the way you can uh
oops wrong button you can
get cars on demand so
um
i prefer
motorcycles when i can
because they're fast and bouncy
so you don't just because they're full
or whatever well you do they're they're
you're not you're you know it's
you're more vulnerable than if you're in
a car yeah
but it's quicker to get places
there's also a fast travel you can go
you can fast travel between your
hideouts okay
is there like a call a taxi function or
anything no
i missed my turn
and bye that's perfectly realistic by
the way on a motorcycle you can run into
street lamps they just they just fall
over
no damage to you or your cycle
there's actually a really cool bit later
in the game where you uh
where you kind of do a tail
you're tailing a boat with you on land
on a motorcycle that's actually super
fun
whoa i missed my turn again excuse me
yeah
i like that when you back up you you do
that i that that seems particularly yeah
like a nice little detail i mean pretty
expected i guess through the pool
i can't
i forget which mission this is
the one's loving the coat physics on the
on the motorcycle there oh this is where
fixer
this is where you uh get invaded oh here
we go yeah this is the invasion is this
simulated or is it another place this is
simulated
so now
i have to find
the dude
and he needs to hack into me but we need
to be
close to each other for those things to
happen okay i need to be in the area
is that how it would normally be or yeah
this is typically how it would normally
be online but two 2x the tap
is uh definitely an ai okay
all right so
here we are now he's gonna start hacking
into me once
he'll he'll easily see me
because you're aiden pierce
well because
he identifies me i'm just identified on
his screen okay
and then you have to start looking at
different people mm-hmm
is that him and that's him
this one was really really easy okay
because he's trying to run away yeah he
starts to run away that's the most fun
thing though when you have
when you have people that can run away
um
the chase could be super fun as
one time
the guy tried to get away from me by
jumping into a pickup truck
and i was right behind him and i jumped
into the rear of the pickup truck i
jumped into the bed and then i planted
um some explosives and jumped out and
then set the explosives off and that's
how i killed him and that was that was
it those are the kind of things where
you can't really
plan that stuff out a lot of pretty cool
so now uh
now can we hack yeah we're gonna we're
gonna do that now
yeah
in fact no time like the present
let's see what kind of contract i can
pick up
fraudulent psychic
using
acupuncture for chained smoking
wedding cancer oh man that's kind of sad
you know
rejected from police academy dude you're
53
hack that person
oh and i unlocked new music
how was the music in this game not great
no
so
hacking begins all right
so you'll see how this looks from the
other angle now okay
but the it's most fun when you're simply
not successful and then the chase begins
when that when the hacker so then
they're chasing you so i won't actually
yes exactly so i won't mind getting
caught necessarily because i actually
like getting caught all right
join failed oh
what uh
what do you get if you successfully hack
somebody
reputation is the big is the biggest
thing and it's it's
uh yeah so it's it's not the most
important thing like in the end i just
do it because i think it's fun
there are there are
rewards that the game gives you
um so you can kind of see
like the notoriety skills that you get
from
from earning notoriety and stuff like
that but honestly
this stuff has never
particularly
interested me all that much
so
so it looks like i have two skill points
so
might as well
open things up while i'm here oh here we
go
let's see if the hopefully the person
won't
cancel the hack yeah oh so you can
just like if yeah if you if if somebody
if somebody doesn't want to participate
they can just refuse
i think
i don't know like whenever i've been
hacked it just says you're being invaded
okay
there you go
can multiple people hack you at once no
not in this type of hack okay
all right so the hacking begins
so that guy's looking for you that guy's
looking for me
but i just oh those people disappeared
right in front of me so i'm gonna
initiate
the hack
so you're just trying to blend in so i'm
just trying to blend in right now and to
him you're just for him i'm just a dude
or a woman i'm just walking around
doing my thing
but i don't want to call a lot of
attention to myself sure
so this is where things can get a little
bit tricky can you sit down on a chair i
cannot
it's i wish it were a little bit more
like assassin's creed multiplayer where
i could just like get close yeah and
then i blend in and it looks like we're
all chatting
and stuff
but my favorite thing to do if i can
is to
get on a get in a vehicle yeah
and then crouch down
so as you go on though the circle is
going to get smaller and smaller
and you have to stay in that circle
we both do you broke that window did you
see you break the window hopefully not
but i'm gonna hide in the car
so now i'm gonna hide in the car this is
this is the unexciting part of a hack
right so
slip space there i think might be able
to find it soon he's coming but i don't
mind being caught that's one of my
favorite so you don't have to run around
you can hack into cameras and look
around that way that can actually be
super efficient
so now we're 50 down so i could actually
if i wanted to sometimes i start driving
around
or but he's like you don't have a lot of
space and you'd have to reverse to stay
in that circle right so he's he's still
running around looking for me yeah the
bad news about that space is that that
that he's then able to narrow down yeah
but he has not
it doesn't take much to identify
somebody all he has to do is basically
just kind of set sights on
on me
driving up i don't know what he what he
was doing about maybe an accident he
might he might have been looking to see
if i was hiding in a car
oh crap
he's checked that place several times
yeah but new people might have uh come
in yeah
like i don't know you might actually get
this i might actually get it he's not um
he hasn't identified me yet
i really actually kind of want him to so
i'm tempted is this it to move but i
think he's going to do it low he's going
to oh crap he's got you get out of here
oh you can't kill him
that is so embarrassing oh that is so
embarrassing when you block yourself
oh my god
damn oh my god i ruined that
it is seriously i can't tell you how
many times i've done that
like
where i've
i've
i get kind of trigger happy and i lift
the barrier before i'm actually across
it
and it's like oh great
good job i basically committed suicide
by by blocking myself
so but it's it's you'd be you'd be
really surprised at how easy it is to do
that all right
i can deal with jodie's job all right so
anyway there's some hacking um let's uh
let's initiate now some
decryption which is
somewhere which is my favorite thing to
do in this game i think
in the meanwhile
when you wait to get into decryption
like yours you basically put your story
and other things on hold oh that was
easy
so this is basically
think of it as a capture the flag
variant so
it's one a team of up to four people
versus another team
and
you have to hold you have to capture
and hold
the the information as long as you can
but other people need to come and take
it from you but to take it from you they
don't even necessarily have to kill you
like they you can just be within range
of you with a certain range and as long
as they stay there they'll steal it from
you
yeah basically so you're
so you're constantly the information's
just constantly being passed around okay
um but you could do all of this in
vehicles on foot
shooting
people can get in the passenger side and
shoot out the window
cool um so that's this is
chaos this this mode can be
super chaotic
sounds fuller yeah
oh yeah let's just finish this we're at
time
so now it's time to steal
so uh yeah
did you join later they just start with
the first i i may have joined late okay
because usually if you're there at the
start yeah then what that means is that
uh there's a spot
where the file isn't okay there's a
matter to pick it up
got it got the file
ugh
oh god damn it
oh man
i was being stolen i want a vehicle
really bad
but
it looks like it's
three on one maybe
hey dude
he's dead
all right no
oh he's jammed the comms
so we can't really tell what's going on
what i really want to do
is get in a vehicle
all right let's get in the semi-truck
so when when is it over
when somebody gets to 100 this wasn't
very fun because i'm at 99
run
oh
crap keep going oh man they're stealing
it they're stealing it
oh i lost the file oh damn it damn it so
so it's a 99
and they just have to get up one yeah
but i think i think the win
is based
on uh
i think the win is based on how long
you've held the file not who happens to
be holding the file at the very end
although there might be a bonus for that
um i'm afraid i'm afraid to talk about
the specifics
of the
of the scoring because i have a feeling
that i'd probably get it wrong
okay
let's uh
let's do another one so we've got we
voted for the next contract so we'll do
a full full game so yeah this will
hopefully be a full game yeah it should
be
the last one was kind of anti-climactic
because i got in when when we were
already at like 90 percent
decrypted so
so everybody starts with weapons yeah
you unlock uh
different
different loadouts okay um as you go
through the game
and then every it warns you that you're
teleporting
and then of course
if only people could have guessed that
by what was on the screen
some fun chat going on
you mean if by chat you mean static
all right so
now you kind of see oop now you kind of
see so there's a mad dash for everybody
to kind of retrieve the file
so i
i may get it
but i'll probably be immediately shot
i've got the file
all right and now
oh one teammate down
there's a street here so and if you're
if you stay in range of your teammates
you
the decryption actually goes faster oh
well um because you're damn it the one
time i actually won a vehicle there i
can't order a vehicle there you go you
can still order vehicle but there's one
over here oh man
if you leave if you play online and you
ever leave matches in progress
you suck
i think everybody left your session
maybe it could so it could be just me
the frame rate just dropped when that
happened too
oh
i won there it is
so it might have just been our internet
or something i don't know can you choose
to join with your friends in a certain
match or is it all just kind of random
places yeah you can there are there are
choices that you can make but i'm you
know what i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna quit the mission
i'm just gonna do something
else
sorry
see that that doesn't count quitting
that right you can't be mad at me for
quitting that was over because it was
because it hadn't started that's right
that's right so i think bonito came in
and said that actually our time was
operating
so that that kind of sucks because now i
just want to play watch dogs all day so
that's uh kind of kind of wrong i guess
is there a penalty for the host leaving
the session i don't think so i don't
think that there are any real penalties
for that kind of stuff
oh we can keep going if we want okay
let's just play a little bit more then
that's good because i like it all right
let's let's uh let's uh head towards uh
head out here we'll we'll unlock uh
another ctos center actually maybe
there's a closer hideout that i can just
teleport to nope we gotta drive we're
gonna drive but it's all right driving's
fast
those are my favorite things to do is
the uh
so now the game is constantly going to
uh
invite me
to do stuff do multiplayer things yes
so
or single player things just when you
get close to something it'll be like hey
dude there's a there's a gang hideout
over here you want to infiltrate that
hey by the way did you know you can do
this hey by the way did you know you
could do that hey hey hey look at me
look at me look at me the game's a
little bit needy it's annoying
just a little bit
hey you know what's awesome this thing i
don't care if you're in the middle of
another thing this other thing's also
awesome sounds like the internet the
thing you're doing isn't awesome enough
i've got another thing right over here
hey
yeah the watch dogs can be a little uh
you know
a little attention seeking
but that's that's it's it's all right
so now we go to pawnee so pawnee as far
as i can tell so pawnee is a real place
in illinois but it's not
close that close to chicago yeah so
here it seems like it's set up to to be
sort of a
a rural
place maybe somebody in chicago can tell
me because i i'm not from chicago so i
don't really know how exactly how well
it handles its geography yeah but i do
know that pawnee is not really uh
it's not a
really a chicago suburb right so i'm
kind of curious if this is just a
representation
of pawnee and they've moved it close to
chicago or if this is actually
representative of something else that's
near chicago that's being called pawnee
here i i sort of wish i knew
as far as i know uh there's nothing
quite this
open
like this one this is close to the city
yeah
i didn't think so i mean
you know usually real-life cities are
condensed in some way
in uh in games um fallout 3 was always
interesting because i used to you know i
lived in dc for a long time
and so
my feelings about about fallout 3 were
always how is it that i can walk from
the washington monument to chevy chase
in five minutes
that doesn't make any sense
and and they you know did that similar
thing uh with grand theft auto 5 where
you have your downtown los santos and
then shortly above you have
desert
right which clearly is not l.a yeah but
at least you know when when you when
it's fictional yeah you can sort of get
away with stuff yeah
so this is this is basically uh
it's another gang thing
so this is a this is a ctos hub
which you need to unlock
to do to get to the the towers
so i'm gonna kind of
boat over i guess
good work thank you glad you liked my
boating
um and now i like when you enter a
combat area how he just kind of
automatically gets into his stealthy
position
so now we know we're
sneaky yeah
but for now
so he can call reinforcements but i
don't yet have
the skill
that uh kind of allows that i was kind
of looking over here to see if i had any
skill hacking skills i could unlock but
i don't
and i'd rather hold on to uh
the skill point
so i'm gonna
see if there's a camera around
so i can explode that dude and i can
distract that dude
so i'm kind of wondering
maybe if i explode that dude
and uh i'm gonna do this
while they're distracted by the
explosion and it looks like i got both
of them too bad we weren't we weren't
really watching that here's uh
a new weapon for me to pick up so you
know now i've got oh and that's some the
goblin's nice too
all right so that dude also i can
explode so i'm just going to quickly
explode him it's more fun to drop to
draw like to draw other dudes close
so now i i don't have enough that that
costs two battery
spots to explode so i don't have enough
so and that recharges oh it does
recharge yeah
but i need to locate the dude with the
access code because i don't want him to
die
um
so i'm oh here's the camera up there i
didn't see it all right so let's take a
look around
there's just
hacking to be done there we go
and actually some dudes have cameras and
then you can just hack into their camera
and are you controlling the movement or
no no he just does his own thing but
this is a good way to like kind of get
out there and see if you can identify
you know or get into places there's
actually a really great
and then sometimes you can get into a
camera that you can't necessarily get to
so hacking that dude
so now i need to hack into the server
and from this point it's anybody's
like i can do it whatever way i want
so i attracted him over there
but i can't really do anything with that
from from the cameras at least
and that burst would be a good
distraction
so
let's uh let's get back into aiden's
body here and stop doing our driver san
francisco stuff
which is kind of how i think about that
and let's see how we're going to get
through here i feel like i haven't
really
done a lot of
shooting so maybe i should just kind of
plow through
maybe
but i see the thing is my my actual
style
in this grenade is going to go off
yep there you go
i like it when because because they can
miss being
um crapped out by their grenade they
they can actually sometimes throw it out
of the way and
and not die and whatnot but sometimes
they'll throw it at some other dude
there were some crafting supplies up
here so you can actually craft various
things which is nice you can grab craft
ieds and and grenades and and all of
your your distraction tools and stuff
like right now i haven't unlocked
that stuff
so i can't really craft anything until i
until i get use that for uh
although now that i've uh
unlocked a skill tree maybe we can
just unlock some of the crafting so now
i can
this way i can make frag grenades let's
let's do that and this way i can do jam
comms which is not also nice to have so
so let's uh
craft some grenades
just like that just like that it doesn't
take much really doesn't take much so
let's just throw a grenade his way
i did a bad job of aiming but i saw his
knee
he didn't die shot him in the butt it's
deadly in the most deadly area
are there dogs in this game um are there
dogs no
no that would be neat though if there
were attack dogs
heads up daria come by come over here i
dare you
oh mistake
oh how'd that gonna see you he totally
missed me yeah the ai's not brilliant
yeah
what uh difficulty setting anyone this
is medium i think okay yeah i think i
don't think that uh
rob was doing anything
so now i have a shotgun
but i killed everybody so
i like how i'm holding it behind me like
that it sort of reminds me of if you've
played persona 3 or something like it
reminds me of
how they how they run with their arms
behind you so now
a little bit of hacking
okay
oops
boom boom
there we go for that one
move that this way
there we go
up
nope
that'll do it
and in we go so
hopefully there will be a hacking a hack
for a randomizer again so we can see if
somebody's up to no good all right here
we go of course here we go randomizer
begins
so dead sec is like the big hacking
group
you'll look younger
it's like an avon party
a little family lunch going on
try here
eventually you want to unlock a hideout
that has a whole bunch of hacks in there
for you to just like look at a bunch of
these but after a while i was like this
doesn't match the tone of the game at
all
so what is the choice
it's unclear
oh so he's the extender he's got a nice
little
so that was his uh cam show
his webcam show so
i think it's very important to note that
the people of chicago were really into
masturbation wow yeah it's a thing they
do something about the chicago thing
yeah
okay
really into it
and for that i say you go chicago
good job
so yeah district access unlocked
so now this is going to mean that uh
yeah it's
new new stuff
are we gonna call it oh that's too bad
the masturbation is done for the day um
so
thanks everybody for coming in and
watching us i mean play watch dogs very
grateful for you joining us
and uh
my thanks to max my thanks to everybody
out there for being awesome and uh you
know we've got lots of stuff coming up
we got lots of stuff on the site today
yeah so make sure to uh stay tuned to
gamespot because what i'm trying to
think what do we got tonight that i need
to play like later this week that i need
to plug i really should have thought
about that before starting the show but
just just read gamespot all the time and
we'll have cool stuff for you all right
and uh i guess we'll we'll see you later
all right see you guys bye